[Music]
[Applause]
bring in Booger McFarland the mothership
NFL college football analyst you got a
favorite Christmas song
um actually it was a song that you guys
were playing this Christmas
um I'm surprised you didn't know that
song also by the way DP
I you know I tune out Christmas music
why is that I I just I don't know what
it is it just it starts at Thanksgiving
and it starts too soon and then I'm I'm
just done with it that's all well as I
sit there and stare at you uh your
studio is definitely in the uh holiday
spirit you got Christmas trees and all
that stuff going on so that uh that's
forced upon me that's forced upon me
right you at least are are exuding uh
the appearance of being a great
Christmas guy yeah yeah it's called
being phony
[Laughter]
oh so booger appears on Monday night
countdown NFL Prime Time each week here
uh give me the downside to name image
and likeness
um
it's not regulated and so basically what
that means is you're getting a a a play
for pay system
um I think name image and likeness was
intended to put money in the player's
pocket because for years the good old
boy system known as NCAA has made a ton
of money off College athletes namely
football players and so when they came
up with name Imaging likeness they were
like okay how can we allow the college
athlete who is technically an amateur
athlete to capitalize on what the NCAA
has been capitalizing on for years
here's the only problem with that DP
there are no regulations so what's legal
in Texas may not be legal in Ohio what's
legal in Louisiana may not be legal in
Alabama as far as how it's governed and
so you get these big boosters that come
up with these collectives which
basically is a group of boosters uh who
come together who say we have a ton of
money and we want to give it to players
so they can come to our University and
we're going to have the best football
team but the best baseball team of
basketball or whatever and so now when
you are the top quarterback uh
quarterback X now the collective from
school ads can say hey we want you to
come to our University and we will pay
you whatever the number is five six
seven eight nine million dollars and so
once you sign now we can come up with a
system where we can pay you this money
and whether you sign autographs or
whether you go work at the luggage store
or or whatever you do but it's turned
into a play for pay system and that's
not what it was intended to but the only
problem is you can't put the toothpaste
back in the tube yeah and so we have a
system now where these college athletes
DP are making more money than some
professional athletes and I don't think
that's what the system was intended for
well Bryce young was making more than
Jalen hurts and Bryce was still in
college and Jalen Hertz is an MVP
candidate it's kind of crazy but I
always go back to in you know Kentucky
basketball players talked about getting
100 handshakes you know booster come up
just give you some when you were at LSU
how what kind of benefits could you get
statue of limitations is over so you can
you can talk about it right yeah was I
taken care of uh handsomely sure uh
nothing crazy and I'm not talking about
well I mean they gave booger a hundred
thousand dollars yeah there were a bunch
of free meals there were a couple of two
three hundred dollar handshakes my
mother never had to worry about paying
for hotel rooms or paying for meals or
food or anything like that and then in
the summertime I got a legit job I mean
I was making 10 15 20 bucks an hour uh I
was able to work uh I don't know six or
seven weeks during the summer I had a
pale Grant I had this thing called the
needy fund and so DP I would I would
guess that if I if I totaled the money I
could make in one calendar year at LSU
if you count my Pell Grant the money I
made this summer I probably made I don't
know 15 grand no here's the difference
now these guys are making five six seven
figures when it comes to just one
calendar year and some of them not don't
even have to work a summer job like I
did so the money is is great it's
handsome and don't get me wrong I'm not
trying to sound like you which is the
old guy on the lawn I'm happy for these
guys that they're able to get some money
I'm gonna be fine with it too booger I'm
if you get it great just let's regulate
it just so we know what's going on
there's no poaching there's no tampering
those kind of things because I brought
this up hypothetically Drake May a
couple of weeks ago I said right what if
he just says hey I'm open for business
here I'm gonna put myself on eBay what
do you want to give me you know he got
offered to uh different deals for five
million dollars to transfer reportedly
and I was just doing a hypo if I'm Ohio
State or Alabama I'm losing my
quarterback to the NFL what's 10 million
dollars to bring in Drake May Drake May
announced he was staying at North
Carolina
be and he couldn't go to the NFL so he
had to announce hey I'm staying and
these rumors
um you know this is where I'm going to
be and the story is over here you know
this is going to happen with these
quarterbacks or you know probably only
quarterbacks somebody's going to go hey
what do you want to pay me and
somebody's going to Pony up 10 million
dollars to bring in so let me ask you
this DP if if the system doesn't get
regulated are you okay with it if it
turns into that I don't want it to be
where it's tampering and and poaching if
if you can somehow have a lifeguard on
duty because it's not the NCAA I just I
want to know where are we headed with
this you want to pay the players or the
players want to get paid I have no
problem with that whatsoever
but I think we got to decide it's almost
like major league baseball there almost
feels like there needs to be the teams
that spend over 200 million dollars
and then the other teams and college
football it's
the schools that make this kind of money
or spend this kind of money and then the
other ones there we we almost need to
have some kind of Separation there
yeah that would seem to be a fair system
and we all know life's not fair so I
don't think we're ever going to get that
system and but I I do understand your
point it would even the playing field
but understand this we've never really
been concerned about the playing field
being even like College of certain
colleges Georgia Ohio State USC have
always been able to spend more on
recruiting than anyone else it doesn't
mean you're going to win it gives you an
advantage but it doesn't mean you're
going to win the title every year
I yeah I don't know where we're headed
I'm just surprised at the so-called
Educators didn't see this happening
where you know a booster is going to go
I'll give you 20 million dollars go and
play with it let's see what we can bring
in give me a couple offensive linemen
and a good defensive lineman and you
know I think that's what's going to be
happening more and more we're talking to
Booger McFarland I didn't mean to get
off on that tangent but uh I more
surprising Geno Smith is a Pro Bowl
quarterback or Aaron Rodgers and Tom
Brady aren't
foreign
Aaron Rodgers and Tom Brady aren't like
we've always seen a talent with Gino
Smith
um I think he his his quote that was
famous uh that they wrote him off but he
didn't write back he's always believed
in his talent he's always been a great
throw of the football uh he just needed
a system and somebody to believe in him
and Pete Carroll uh whether it was by
luck or by choice believed in him
because let's not forget Pete Carroll
traded for Drew lock and a lot of people
thought Drew lock was going to be the
starter but when you get to Tom Brady
and Aaron Rodgers I think Tom Brady's is
the most surprising DP because he led
the NFL in passing last year he was
phenomenal uh had that great comeback
against the Rams and in the divisional
Playoff round and he seemingly fell off
a cliff like he's been bad this year DP
I mean he has been bad just about every
Sunday and we continue to try to make
excuses for him or we continue to uh
wait for uh to go to show up because he
is the greatest quarterback of all time
I haven't seen it and it doesn't matter
to me about the issues he's had off the
field like everybody has things that
they go through in life what matters is
when you show up you're a professional
you do your job I don't want to hear
about well he was going through a lot
who cares we all go through a lot as far
in Rogers is concerned you knew it was
going to be a transition early on
because he was breaking in new receivers
and uh Bachi I already left tackle was
coming off an injury so I kind of
expected him to be a little slower kind
of getting into the season but I'm I I
am still surprised that both he and Tom
with Tom being the biggest surprise
aren't in the Pro Bowl because we expect
so much from him we have these
Standalone games you have that game
tonight with the Jets and the Jags and
everybody's going to have an opinion on
a game that nobody would have an opinion
on if it was played Sunday at one
o'clock but everybody's going to have a
referendum on Trevor Lawrence and Zach
Wilson how do you think this plays out
tonight between these two
I think this is going to be a
contrasting style
um the Jets at their core are defensive
lead football team that wants to be
physical but they have a quarterback
that drafted number two overall so they
kind of have to break him in a little
bit and he's uh he's been highly
scrutinized I myself have scrutinized
him a lot when you look at Jacksonville
they have a quarterback that's ascending
Trevor Lawrence has made great strides
this year as far as being The Golden
Child and we thought he was going to be
when he came out of Clemson so you have
two teams that that want to play uh a
physical brand of football one has their
quarterback going up and Trevor Lawrence
the other I don't really know what Zach
Wilson is but I do know he was drafted
number two overall and the expectations
are right there with Trevor Lawrence and
you're right we're gonna judge both of
these guys namely the quarterbacks
tonight more than we are going to judge
the teams and I think if if you're Zach
Wilson the game tonight in a standalone
game as the holidays are here so more
people are going to be sitting at home
with eggnog I know you won't because you
don't like Christmas but more people
people are going to be sitting around
with eggnog and a glass of wine saying
you know what let me see what this guy
Zach Wilson is about so tonight is an
important game for him
I do think he's got to show up and play
well I think the Jets are a better
football team a more talented team
um but it doesn't mean that they're
going to win tonight
I was watching a Monday night countdown
as I always do and you uh talked about
staying warm and you'd occasionally have
some whiskey
yeah
listen DP how much I'm a southern boy
how much whiskey would you have prior to
a game do to stay warm well well I'm not
talking about enough whiskey to make you
feel like that you're Invincible I'm
just talking about enough whiskey to
give you a little warmth going down your
throat and just uh just a thin before a
little sip for because what it does I'm
not a drinker okay I've never been drunk
one day in my life as I've gotten older
I've learned to change my palate and I
drink the occasional cab and then you
and I can hang out and sip on a little
Camus every now and then which I'm
looking forward to by the way uh but I'm
only talking about a thimble Force
enough to warm the throat burn your
throat almost and kind of give you a
little tingling sensation that's kind of
what I did how many players would do
that
uh that were three or four I'm not gonna
name those players I I'll just
incriminate myself but uh there was a
game in Green bay where the windshield
was -15 the actual temperature was zero
and the only way I was there were two
ways I was able to play in that game one
I had a full body onesie on that I cut
the toes out of and two I had two shots
of whiskey one pre-game and then one
after halftime
how was that how'd you guys play
uh we actually won had one of my better
games
um I think overall uh boog's not a fan
of cold weather DP not a fan whatsoever
like there are a lot of things in life
I'd rather do than be outside in cold
weather so if you watch the broadcast of
the night and people said man you look
miserable it's because
hey it's great to talk to you as always
uh Merry Christmas to you and uh we'll
talk to you in the new year
DP have a great one have a great
Christmas yeah celebrated to the fullest
yeah absolutely it's only I can that's
uh Booger McFarland of the mothership
we'll take a break our play of the day
is coming up next